In the last video, we talked about the different ways
to present the central trend or the average of a plurality of data.
In this video we will look at this more broadly,
to understand how they are distracted
data.
Let's just think a little about this.
Let's say we have 10, 0, 10, 20 and 30.
Let's say that there is one set of data there.
Let's say the other set of data is 8, 9, 10, 11 and 12.
Let's now calculate the arithmetic mean for both
sets of data.
Let's calculate the average value.
When you become more familiar with the statistics, you will
you understand the difference between
aggregate and sample.
I assume this is all
a set of data.
So we will have an average value for the general population.
We will have a job, as you will see,
with the measures of the general population for dissipation.
I know all these are complex words.
Next, you will not have all the data given.
You will have some extras from them
you will try to calculate things for the whole
general population.
I do not want to worry too much about this now.
But if you go on with the statistics,
I want to make this point.
The average value of the aggregate or the arithmetic mean of that
a set of data here is -10 plus 0, plus 10,
plus 20, plus 30 on - we have 5 data points - on 5.
How equal is this?
Minus 10 is truncated with plus 10, 20 plus 30 is 50,
divided by 5 is equal to 10.
What is the average value of this data set?
8 plus 9, plus 10, plus 11, plus 12, the whole on 5.
The way we can look at it is 8 plus 12 is 20, 9
plus 11 is also 20, so we have 40 then
we will have 50 there.
Add 10 more.
Again we will have 50 on 5.
So it has exactly the same average of the general population.
Or if you do not want to use the word cluster or
sampling and all that both sets of data have
exactly the same arithmetic mean.
When we take the average of all these numbers and divide by 5 or
when we have the sum of these numbers and divide by 5,
you get 10, some of these numbers and divide by 5,
you also get 10.
But it is clear that these sets of numbers are different.
If you just look at this number,
that maybe they are very similar to each other multitudes.
But when you look at these two sets of data, you can
to notice something.
All these numbers are very close to 10.
I mean, the farthest number here is 2 out of 10.
12 is just 2 out of 10.
Here these numbers are more than 10.
Even the closest ones are at a distance of 10, and these are at a distance
20 of 10.
So this multitude of data is here
more scattered, right?
This data is at a greater distance than the average
of the average.
Let's think about the different ways we can measure
the statistical scattering or the distance we are from
center, on average.
One way, this is a kind
the simplest way is the span.
You will not see it used very often, but it is in a sense a lot
a simple way to understand at what distance is the distraction between
the largest and the smallest number.
We literally take the largest number, which is 30 c
the example and we deduct the smallest number.
30 minus -10, which is equal to 40, which shows us,
that the difference between the biggest and the smallest
the number is 40, so for this set of data we have a 40.
Here the range is the largest number, 12, minus the smallest
a number that is 8, which is equal to 4.
So here the span is actually a good measure for
statistical scattering.
We say well, both sets have an arithmetic mean of 10.
But when I look at the wobble, it's got bigger
which shows me that it is a more scattered crowd.
But the scale will not always give you a complete picture.
You may have two sets of data with exactly the same width
where, based on how the numbers are grouped,
may nevertheless have a very different distribution
of the numbers.
The thing you will see most commonly used,
is called variation of data.
In fact, we will see the standard
deviation in this video.
It is probably the most commonly used, but there are many
close relationship with the coefficient of variation.
The sign of the variance - as will
we are dealing with variation of the general population.
Once again, we assume that this is all the data
of the whole population that we have not only a sample,
we do not have just a piece of data.
The sign of variation is literally this sign sigma,
this Greek letter, square.
This is the sign of variation.
We will see that this letter sigma is actually the sign
for the standard quadratic deviation.
That's why.
But in any case the definition of variance is,
that you take each of these points with data you find the difference
between them and the average value, you raise them squarely
then calculate the average of these squares.
I know this sounds very complicated, but when
actually calculate it, you will see that it's not that bad.
Remember that the average value here is 10.
So I take the first data point.
I'll write it here.
I'll roll a little down.
I get the first data point.
Minus 10.
From it I will take the arithmetic mean and
I will raise him to a square.
I just found the difference from the first data point to
the average value and raised it to a square.
This essentially makes it a positive number.
Plus, the second data point, 0, minus 10,
this is the average value; we have this 10 here is a square plus
10, minus 10 per square - we have this 10 here in the middle -
plus 20 minus 10 - that's 20, square
plus 30 minus 10 per square.
This is the square difference between each
number and arithmetic mean.
This is the arithmetic mean.
I find the difference between each data point and
the average value, I pick up a square and collect them, then
divide the number of data points.
I therefore calculate the average of these numbers,
from squares to squares.
When you say it aloud, it sounds a lot
complicated.
But you take every number.
The difference between it and the average value you raise in a square
and calculate the average of them.
So there are 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, divided by 5.
How will this be equal?
Minus 10, minus 10 is minus 20.
Minus 20 per square is 400.
0 minus 10 is minus 10, squared is 100, so we have plus 100.
10 minus 10 per square is simply 0 per square, which is 0.
Plus, 20 minus 10 is 10 per square, which is 100.
Plus 30 minus 10, which is 20, the square is 400.
All this on 5.
What do we have here?
400 plus 100 is 500 plus 500 plus 1000.
It equals 1000/5, which equals 200.
So in this situation the coefficient of variation will be 200.
This is the measure of distraction here.
Let's compare it to this set of data here.
Let's compare it with the coefficient of variation
of this less scattered set of data.
I'll turn a little to get some space,
although it ends me.
Maybe I can scroll up.
Here.
Let me calculate the coefficient of variation for this set of data.
We already know its average value.
The coefficient of variation for this set of data will be 8
minus 10 per square, plus 9 minus 10 per square, plus 10 minus 10
square plus 11 minus 10 - let's roll a little up -
per square, plus 12 minus 10 per square.
Remember that 10 is the average we calculated.
You must first calculate the average value. Partitioned - we have 1,
2, 3, 4, 5 elevated squares.
So this will be equal to - 8 minus 10 minus 2,
the square is plus 4.
9 minus 10 minus 1, square plus 1.
10 minus 10 is 0 per square.
You also get 0.
11 minus 10 is 1.
You pick him up in a square and get 1.
12 minus 10 is 2.
You pick him up in a square and get 4.
And how is that equal?
All this is on 5.
We have 10/5.
So we'll have 10/5, which is
equal to 2.
So the coefficient of variance here - let me make sure that I got it right.
Yes, we have 10/5.
The variation of this less scattered set of data is
much smaller.
The coefficient of variation of this data set here is only 2.
So that gives you some idea.
It shows that this is definitely less scattered
a lot of data than that there.
The problem with the coefficient of variation is that
you have the difference between these numbers and
the arithmetic mean by lifting it in a square.
This gives you a little arbitrary number and if
you're dealing with units, let's say
if these are distances.
It's minus 10 meters, 0 meters, 10 meters, that's 8
meters and so on, then when you lift up a square,
you get the coefficient of variation in terms of square meters.
This is a strange set of units.
That's why people like to talk about the standard
a deviation that is just a square root of the coefficient of variation
or a square root of a square sigma.
And the standard sign
deviation is simply sigma.
Now that we find the coefficient of variation is very easy
to find the standard deviation of both
sets.
The standard deviation of the first
multiple data will be a square root of 200.
Square root of 200 is how much?
Square root of 2 in 100.
This is equal to 10 square root of 2.
This is the first set of data.
The standard deviation for the second set of data
will be just the square root of its coefficient of variation, which is 2.
So the second set of data has 1/10 of the standard deviation of
the first set.
This is 10 by root of 2, and it's just a root of 2.
This is 10 times the standard deviation.
Let me give you a slightly better idea.
Let's think of it.
This has a 10 times higher standard deviation than that.
Let us remember how we calculate it.
With the coefficient of variation, we simply take every set of data at what distance it is
of the average, we raise to a square
and we calculate the average of them.
Then we calculate the square root, really just to look
units well, but the end result is that we say the first one
a set of data has 10 times the standard deviation of
the second set.
Let's look at the two sets of data.
This has a 10 times higher standard deviation, which makes sense
intuitively, right?
I mean, they both have 10 here, but each one of them,
9 is only a unit distance of 10, 0 is at a distance of 10
of 10, by 10 less.
8 is just 2.
This is at a distance of 20.
So we average 10 times longer.
So the standard deviation, at least for me, gives us
a much better idea of ​​what distance on average
we are from the arithmetic mean.
In any case, hopefully find this useful.